how are you breaking up the days like
what what's your what's your schedule
like what what's happening in your world
when you wake up is this for TV or this
for everyday okay
I'm finding little chores throughout my
day like I organize my spice rack I gave
my powder room a remodel like I painted
and installed a new mirror I swept and
organized the garage so basically I hit
rock bottom I also understand that
you've married construction and fitness
at the same time you got a Fitness bike
yeah I put it together myself and it's
right over there do you go on it I have
been on it took what I'm doing a really
good job I think you got to keep
yourself motivated you know is it more
like a coat rack at this point there has
been a coat on it gets folded up Oh
bless oh it's great though
it's put together real solid yeah I
really did a great job stay strong guys
are you finding it harder than you
thought it would be it's not easy I miss
dating I miss like being out there I
miss happy hours so when you talk about
dating are you perusing are you perusing
any apps and things like that well you
know what's on the apps and I got kicked
off for impersonating a famous person
and like I said I actually wrote an
email back I was like thank you for
started but if I if I was gonna
impersonate a famous person no shade to
me but do you think I would choose Ross
Matthews alright well thank you so much
for taking the time okay I adore you and
text me and I'll tell you the off TV
stuff that I do
[Laughter]